the other day my cat Congress kept
trying to pee he was in his litter box
for like 10 minutes then I found him in
the bathtub then he was in the corner of
my office back to the bathtub and I had
to take him to his litter box again all
in like an hour
so finally I did some google searching
to figure out what the hell was going on
and it turns out that this is a
dangerous sign among cats because they
can have an infection or blockage which
can be fatal
now there are two kinds of people in a
crisis those who are good at handle it
and get things done and those who freeze
and in those freezing moments your
imagination runs freakin wild until it
gets to the point where you're all misuk
i you can't congress's I'm sure you know
what I mean it's like when you hear
strange noise in the house and for a
split second you're like oh my god
there's a serial killer rapist who's
broken into my home until you realize oh
I know I have four pets the imagination
can be a great thing but I think you
have to be careful otherwise you'll fall
into paranoid thinking and eventually
indulge in dark fantasies and I don't
think that's healthy
no oh Congress is fine by the way
he's got to switch over to a bladder
healthy diet for the rest of his life
and he's high he's on drugs right now
like running around and he's extra
prairie and cuddly because I guess he's
basically on opium
so I'm then that makes cats really
loving so I was like hey give me a
lifetime supply that OPM will give it
all my cat so the love me oh yeah I'll
see you next week stay awesome Gotham